foreign
[Music]
hey everybody it's Monday yep and we're
doing another hanuk show a haunting
already like the weeks are just going by
it seems like we were just doing this I
know it goes by fast man we're anxious
now a week goes by I feel like an hour
but this one's called the Diabolical
diabolical
I'm diabolical as [__] I thought this
was about me yeah yeah it's it's not
spoiler no it's not about me they should
make an episode about you yeah well they
wanted to one or two Lois red didn't
want to [__] do it though well they
wanted to do it they didn't want they
didn't want any film crews in their
house yeah and they were like you know
it's a long story I was like okay [__]
it it didn't matter that was during the
time where the haunting was starting to
suck anyway I'd have been icon season
nine
no I think it would have been like seven
maybe
oh no you probably would have been like
11 or 12. okay like I don't know how far
back it was yeah I mean it was a few
years ago but I don't even think it's on
anymore
Ben said wasn't sure if I would make
your start the previous livecast I was
watching spend an hour and a half
reading out their super chats holy [__]
what an hour and a half reading out
super chats our super chats now oh okay
you missed the whole first part of that
did not understand what he said
or what
I think it was probably just you
worthless yeah
because that's usually what happens
but yeah so this was another season one
episode that I thought we had talked
about uh probably I I thought we had
talked about it because back when we
were watching these all the time you
used to like do that diabolical like all
the time and so I was like oh we must
have covered it at some point but we
never did we know I know why too I
remember we went good we checked the
Diabolical early on to see if it'd make
a good show and there were other ones
that would have made better shows yeah
that's probably that's what happened
well and the thing about this one too is
that because
I think we always tried to avoid like
when we did whole shows about them I
think we always tried to avoid episodes
that didn't have the real people like
where the people were just in Shadow or
they were using pseudonyms or whatever
which this one does because it was you
know you couldn't find out anything like
extraneous information
you couldn't very verify anything yeah
because this isn't
you know the real person is not I mean
the real paranormal investigators are on
there and they show their faces but the
actual person is yeah it was in a phase
where we were trying to do kind of a
better pair like a parapsychological
analysis of of each case but some of
these cases you can't do it because
there's just not enough information
so and so instead on The Haunting shows
that we're doing now
it's more like a review of the episode
and a discussion of the episode yeah you
know uh we can come up with some ideas
so we're not trying to ver you know
verify it or debunk it or anything we're
just gonna talk about it yeah and I mean
it's a good episode or not right and I
mean the thing about it is like if I
could have found like some other
information about it then yeah then I'll
talk about that but this one because
um they weren't using their real names
that's just uh the way it rolls you know
what I mean so I couldn't find anything
uh else about this one so again this is
a season one episode eight
the bottle yeah it's about time but not
really no
diabolical two yeah epic tomlinness
but Jenny used to like me to say that
[__] she thought that [__] was sexy
climbing up on her and [__] bed and
[__] I got the time
[Laughter]
aphrodisiacs
that's why that's why she remembers
I didn't remember much about the actual
episode I just remembered the title of
it because she said this [__] low on
Gravely yeah
for a long time when I was watching I
was like why is this even called the
Diabolical because I didn't really but
then like when it gets to know yeah like
they don't because this one is another
one that has um churchy stuff yeah
churchy stuff uh David considine he is a
demonologist yeah and I gotta say he's
not a bad one at least as far as the
episode goes I mean
is basic his basis a lot of the methods
he's using or at least that they show
him use in this
Arcana based upon parapsychology too
you know I mean the methods of
Investigation but we're not there so I
don't know if he actually does this it's
just how it was betrayed in the episode
or whatever but nowhere near as hokey is
like Ed Warren
yeah that's true nowhere near that
hoagie I think he was
if he believed it he was trying to get
down to the bottom of it but of course
you know if if religion's involved it's
always good it's got to stick to
scripture so you know demons
this demons easy that's what they're
gonna go for yeah it's like why even
bother investing was like we don't have
to come to the house we already know
damn it yeah even though there's some
strange
strange facts about this case you know I
mean there's a mentally handicapped girl
involved which a parapsychologists that
have been interested in that
because who knows maybe uh
a person with they don't really say
what's wrong with her but it's something
mental some having to do their brain
well I think it was a lot of things but
all they said was like birth defects
because they said she couldn't walk
either yeah well who knows I mean you
know uh what if she what if she was
exhibiting [__] rspk you know what if
she was slight had psychokinesis
you know it's a possibility because you
know certain parts of her brain might
have been inactive and then other more
obscure parts of her brain might have
been very active you know what I mean
trying to compensate and maybe she maybe
it was just you know a poltergeist from
her subconscious you know they don't
know
hard to say yeah I think that's what
kind of made this uh episode sort of
interesting and and this guy as a demon
as a demonologist never considered that
because he's going to jump right to
Demons demons and ghosts yeah
yeah which we'll get into I mean he did
say that she was the focus of it or the
center of it but not in a not in a
poltergeist kind of way more in like a
demonic oppression watching it that's
what I was leaning to because
Poltergeist exhibits a lot of the
attributes of what a religious person
would call demonic possession
yeah yeah it I think demonic possession
the original poultry the original
[__] demonic possession case that
made the [__] famous the one that they
based uh what you call it on The
Exorcist on was a poltergeist case it
wasn't
yeah they were trying to exercise it but
it was a poltergeist
some of the pre that one priest that saw
it when he was young he was helping with
the exorcism he goes oh this was
they're exercising it but this is uh
this is definitely Poltergeist you know
there's drawers opening and things being
thrown and he was that I don't think it
was a demon you know
but you know he was in his 20s he
couldn't say anything I don't think
anything or any of them were demons yeah
he's not a poltergeist so from the
interview that I saw yeah he thought
they were making it worse but you know
which I think that's
that's true well I mean that usually
does happen in these kind of situations
yeah Trey says Hey guys at work again so
can't stay have fun oh that's a shame
well listen I mean you can listen later
yeah he always does all right so let's
get into this a little bit now like I
said
uh the woman who's like the mom uh she
was the one that was on there mostly I
think her boyfriend slash husband
whatever I think he was on there too but
they were both in Shadow so they
actually called her Marie Potter that's
not her real name I'm presuming because
she didn't want her identity known and
uh the one daughter that she had that
was kind of like uh the disabled
daughter was named Julie
so this apparently took place in the
Hudson Valley in Upstate New York which
uh Anthony called the narrator said that
some people call the Devil's Playground
oh yes I was like all that do they some
people do he's probably local
another one was a producer yeah
so see people it's more than one person
some people some people some people the
people right here in this studio we
decided that that's what it's called see
we're calling them out
maybe it's called that I don't know I
don't know I've never heard that but you
know what I mean I've never heard that
but that doesn't mean it's not the case
because I'm not from there yeah so if
you're from there like and they're like
oh yeah they absolutely do so everybody
knows that that's what they call it the
Devil's Playground we call it that all
the time yeah I kind of doubt it though
Jenny just got home from work man
weights just falling off her I'm looking
she's
she's looking so sexy right now
I've been here by myself a little time
just she's getting hourglass [__]
shape and everything man every man knows
what I'm going through every man watch
and understands
damn uh Poor Tom because she's too tired
man she's gonna go there and go to sleep
I know well yeah because I've been up
since quarter to four okay this morning
I have to deal with it I woke up like
really early and I couldn't go back to
sleep I have to deal with it I have
terrible insomnia okay but you know what
I mean yeah I said I was man it's like I
just want to take a shower and grab a
Little Debbie and watch watch Dan Bell
or something I'm making sure I'm not
Sidetrack at this [__] program this
[__] is going on too long okay all right
and then you're gonna like talk yourself
into like all this and then it'll be
like four hours and then I'm gonna fall
asleep on my keyboard and I'll just be
like yeah like that all right let's get
back into it but yeah so uh where were
we yeah is the Hudson Valley really
called The Devil's Playground I don't
know I don't know I I'm not from there
so apparently
apparently Dory first started taking
place in the Autumn of 1998.
so Marie uh again not her real name but
I'm that's the last time I want to say
that is a single mom
and she has three kids uh one named Paul
one named Angela and one named Julie now
Julie all they said about her they
didn't say specifically like what was
you know the matter with her they just
said that she had severe birth defects
um she can't walk she can't talk like
she can't really do anything for herself
you know what I mean so yeah so she's
like disabled
um so they lived in this house now okay
so the way they put it they said well
they lived in this house for three years
so I guess it wasn't a case where it's
like oh we moved into this place and all
this like weird paranormal [__] started
happening apparently they lived in this
house for a few years now the whole time
that they lived in the house evidently
Julie they said she always acted like
she was looking at or reacting to like
invisible people and they weren't
entirely sure if that was just like a
thing that she did and it didn't mean
anything or if she was like seeing
actual beings of some kind do you know
what I mean
um her mom said it's like it seemed like
she was like someone an invisible person
was like playing peekaboo with her
because it's like she'd always like you
know how like a kid gets her faces like
oh what's going on oh you know what I
mean they're like surprise it's like she
would do that all the time like somebody
was playing peekaboo with her now Marie
said
that she thought it was Angels which I
was like okay okay but um well she was
like because she's like her daughter was
like such a pure soul and bloody blah so
it's like you know it obviously couldn't
be anything bad so maybe it's like her
guardian angels or like whoever's like
looking out for or whatever and I was
just like okay I'm gonna say okay
um so in 1998 uh Marie goes back to like
where she was from which is Brooklyn and
she was like being with her friends and
they introduced her to this dude named
Chris and the two of them hit it off and
they kind of like start a relationship
now Chris comes over to the house a few
weeks later
but as soon as he comes inside he said
he felt really oppressed he said it felt
like there was no air in there and that
something like really bad was happening
so he tells Marie later he's like uh you
know I was real into like the Paranormal
as a teenager and I did like a lot of
reading about it and stuff and I said I
don't really want to scare you but when
I came in your house like it felt really
[__] weird in there and I just feel
like it's not good now she's like oh
well you know I thought that there was
maybe like you know good spirits or
Angels or something like that in the
house because she said like what Julie
had been acting like and stuff he's like
I don't think it's Angels he's like
whatever's in here I don't think it's
good
um you know like again I don't want to
scare you but that's just kind of like
where where I'm coming from he said some
[__] that reminded me of Mammoth
Mountain yeah he said he walked in there
and he felt it was like oppressive like
it was real closed in feeling even
though it was a wide open room yeah
something was pressing down on him and
that's that's the way it felt the second
he walked in
to that uh condominium at Mammoth
Mountain it was like he walked into a
high pressure Zone there's no way to
describe it but you feel it when you go
when you walk into a place like that so
I'm already thinking it's Poltergeist
yeah like I guess he was implying that
it was kind of like a suffocating sort
of feeling because he said it felt like
there was no air yeah I know he's
talking about yeah that's what he said
it felt like as soon as he walks in the
door there's no way to describe it you
just have to send you have to sense it
yourself it's just like something's
watching you and it's bearing down on
you it's like a high pressure
uncomfortable feeling in there
then you leave and and you can go you
can kind of sense that it's over there
now
you know what I mean yeah and then you
go in you you're like oh I'm in it now
and then you jump back up and go now I
feel it over there yeah you know it's
like a Zone like a Zone you're right
so a few days later like after Chris's
visit I'm presuming
Marie uh comes downstairs one morning
like you know trying to wake the kids up
for school or whatever and the living
room is kind of it's not trash but it's
just kind of like covered with toys like
the kids have been out there like we
like throwing all the toys around
everywhere like it look like that
and the mom like presumed she presumes
obviously that it's her son Paul is like
what the [__] like why are you throwing
toys all over the room and it's like why
didn't you clean it up or anything like
that and Paul's like I didn't do it the
boy with the yellow hair did it
and the mom's like who's the boy with
the yellow hair and it's just like oh he
plays in the living room and then he
said I don't want him in my room and I
was like ooh that's creepy wouldn't that
be creepy if like your kids said that to
you he plays in the living room because
I don't want him in my room that's what
he said uh so yeah a boy with a yellow
hair
now the other daughter Angela uh she
apparently was in her room one night and
here's like some kind of weird noises
and then she also sees a boy like
briefly like standing I think he was
standing next to Julie's bed it looked
like it was kind of dark I couldn't
really tell and I was like taking notes
at the same time so I kept like you know
looking up and down
so she runs into her mom's room and says
hey there's a boy with blonde hair
in the in the bedroom and you know the
mom goes in there and like obviously the
kid's not there like when Mom goes to
check because you know it's a ghost or
whatever but uh she said Angela was like
very insistent mom it was in here and
she gets kind of like mad about it
So eventually uh Marie and Chris kind of
get you know the relationship gets a lot
closer Chris ends up moving in with them
so they kind of become a little family
unit or whatever
now one night the family are all eating
dinner at the table and they see a boy
outside like peeking in the window and
it's like night time so it's not really
a time when kids would be like running
around they didn't really say
if the boy because they immediately jump
to that's a ghost
like they went outside and there was
nobody there and then like it seemed
like the swing was like kind of swinging
by itself right
and so they immediately jumped to well
that's a ghost I'm like I would kind of
think oh maybe that's just like a
neighbor kid but I don't know maybe he
looked clearly like a ghost and not like
a real kid because they didn't even they
just jumped right past hey it's maybe
it's the neighbor kid into yeah that's
probably a ghost so there must have been
some something about that ghost how it
looks like just peeking in the window
hey you got brussels sprouts in there
yeah you know what I mean I kind of feel
like yeah you want butter
[Laughter]
ghost just wants to come in and like
have some food man that's all
so uh so Marie and Chris well mostly
Chris like he decides he's like oh like
I said I'm the Paranormal expert here
like uh not me but Chris is apparently
the Paranormal expert he's like we
should get uh Ouija board and uh see if
we can communicate with this supposed
little boy ghost and see what he wants
uh Marie is just kind of like I don't
know man I don't think it's a good idea
but Chris is all uh oh I you know I
totally know what I'm doing
and I was like laughing at this point
because I'm just like he doesn't know
what he's doing but he thought he did
so the two of them sit down and start
doing the Ouija board right
so they're like you know they do the
whole thing is there somebody in here
yada yada yes and then it spells out the
name Frank so the ghost is named Frank
and then basically Chris is like well
what do you want or something like that
and then
um the ghost puts like uh initials that
says JP
now Chris is just like what the [__]
does that mean but Maria is like oh
that's Julie's initials you know it
means that means it wants Julie and he's
like well I don't know if we can like
jump to that conclusion I'm like yeah
you might be like reaching a little bit
there but you know what I mean
um but Chris is like okay well I'll ask
it well what exactly do you want with
Julie but then the ghost wouldn't answer
so then he's like okay well is there
another ghost here we can talk to
because Frank got really rude and like
[__] up apparently so it's like we
want another ghost
so then they're like okay so someone
else is there and then it goes to Yes
again and then it spells out the name
Adam and then it spells out the word Sun
as in s-o-n
Chris freaks the [__] out
because he tells Marie that his ex-wife
aborted a fetus which I'm presuming he
didn't say this outright but I'm
presuming they were going to name it
Adam I don't well it seemed like
I don't know it's just he didn't say
that so I'm just kind of like I think he
was again jumping to conclusions but
he's become convinced that this is his
unborn son his aborted son right like
coming back to haunted and I'm just like
okay again that seems like a reach
so um so yeah so that wigs him out
so then Chris here's like this kind of
weird screaming noise it sounded like uh
but I guess Marie doesn't hear it and
then everything just kind of like busts
out like everything starts the table
starts rattling like all the [__] you
know the light fixtures are swinging
it's like all they start hearing like
weird noises like out in the hallway and
[__] like that like everything just like
goes crazy
so Chris
um is like well that was a stupid idea
and then he goes and burns the Ouija
board on the grill now anybody that has
seen a haunting more than what you know
you never ever ever burn a Ouija board
yeah that's that's always bad news
they always tell you not to do that and
I was like oh you're asking for it now
you're asking for it now yeah you burned
it you're not opening it up you're
opening into Portal now you can't close
it because you put her to the door yeah
it's all kinds of X that's that's
essentially what they're saying but it's
just like I kind of laugh because I'm
like bro I told you he didn't know what
you were doing everybody knows you know
[__] Ouija board
so then a few days later Marie is in the
basement doing laundry because women are
always doing laundry on a haunting I
think I pointed that out before I guess
because it's like an activity that you
can do in the house that so it looks
like they're doing something you know
what I mean instead of just like sitting
on the couch but um yeah so she's out of
the basement doing laundry and while
she's downloaded like the door up into
the kitchen like closes by itself
and then she looks at the back of the
door and it looked like
white handprints she's like it was
clearly paint like it wasn't wet but
she's like it looked like dry white
paint but she's like but one those
handprints had not been there before so
where the [__] did they come from and
he's like two
um we don't have any white paint in the
house and the hand prints are not the
size of any of anybody in the house like
any of her kids or anything like that so
again where the [__] did these prints
come from
so at this point they're like okay we're
gonna call a paranormal investigator
now the Paranormal Investigator says
well you know maybe one of your kids is
playing a prank or something like that
one should you like the baby powder
trick where you put you know the baby
powder all over the floor so you can see
like Lenny little Footprints or whatever
if the kids are coming in a [__] ramp
so they do that they put like baby
powder all over the um the floor in the
basement
the next morning they go down to the
basement and they find writing in the
powder
but there are no Footprints and they're
like where the writing is there is no
way that you had been able to like write
in the powder without standing in the
powder do you know what I'm saying yeah
now uh the writing says Lilith which I
was sitting there going like oh like
female demon like are we talking about
the biblical Lilith is it gonna are we
gonna go in that direction because I
didn't remember like what the show was
about
but uh they call the Paranormal
Investigator and she comes in she's like
you know you gotta come see this [__]
like come and check this out so the
Paranormal Investigator comes over to
look and then she's like do you know who
Lilith is and they're like no and she's
like yeah I'm out apparently Lilith was
her daughter was I who I'm presuming is
dead
so that wigged her out because she's
like whatever the [__] it is in your
house is like taunting me or something
like that and I'm not I'm not gonna like
take this [__] case because no
so she left
so uh Marie has probably not
surprisingly had trouble sleeping in the
weeks since they used the Ouija board
and here there's like a dream sequence
where Marie dreams that she goes into
the backyard and sees Frank who is this
presumed person that they were talking
to through the Ouija board
Frank tells her that she's stupid I'm
like nice okay rude ghost and that she
can't help Julie like he's gonna take
her like no matter what or whatever
so she wakes up and she tells Chris hey
there's a man in the backyard who wants
Julie but Chris is like it was just a
dream chill the [__] out even though
Chris was like ooh Mr paranormal like at
the beginning but now he's just like
doing that whole thing again it's like
it's not real blah blah so I was just
like make up your mind
meanwhile
stuff kind of starts moving in the kids
room like I well I guess like the girls
were in one room and I guess like the
the little boy Paul was in the other
room so I guess it was in Paul's room so
he had like a ball and like some other
toys and [__] like that like on top of
his dresser and it started um like
rattling like all crazy like you know
Poltergeist here what not and then he
sees like a face coming through the wall
um which you know obviously like he
freaked the [__] out and like screamed
and everything
so the next day Marie had to go into
Paul's room and move his bed away from
the wall because he's free so like he'll
still sleep in the room but he's not
gonna sleep next to the wall that the
face came out of you know what I mean
which you know that's that's fair enough
and while she's moving the bed around
she finds like a weird it looks like
some kind of a symbol like burned into
the foot not like a pentagram or nothing
like that but I thought
was it supposed to be her daughter's
initials like like a JP I don't know I
don't know but she said yeah it looked
like a symbol I couldn't really tell
what it was but she said it looked like
it was burned into the floor I think she
said that it was like the the daughter's
initials
now at this point uh her and Chris are
like maybe we should move you know what
I mean but um they are kind of like well
they probably correctly
um presume that well if this is a spirit
it's attached to Julie and not to the
house so if we move it'll just come with
us so what's the point you know what I
mean so at least they had the
wherewithal to like knew that
so a few weeks weeks after that uh Marie
goes down to the basement again for
whatever reason and Chris is down there
but he's acting really [__] weird she
said he was like sitting against the
wall and she's like there's a light in
the basement but it usually like points
the other way but this time like the
light was like pointing toward him like
it was a spotlight type of thing I don't
know if the light was movable or if that
was like a paranormal thing she didn't
really specify but she's like yeah like
spotlighting him and he was like talking
in this weird ass voice and he was
saying stuff like um you don't know who
I am I'm not Chris blah blah blah I'm
like oh she's like what the [__] is the
matter with you you know what I mean
um so yeah obviously like he's got all
possessy and she's like yeah well you
know that's that's yeah
uh Julian Pope said it was the letter f
for Frank oh okay okay that's I knew it
was a letter but I couldn't remember
because I thought I wrote it down but of
course I did not because I'm trying to
like write notes really fast like while
I'm watching it
so I don't have to keep stopping it you
know what I mean
so uh so yeah so Marie is just like I
don't know what the [__] is going on
with that like like I said he's acting
all crazy and so she runs outside and
then he comes out like after you know
after a couple minutes and she's like
what the hell was that all about and
she's like I don't really remember like
I don't remember what happened like I
don't remember anything I said or
anything like that
um so then they jump ahead to like Marie
I guess it's later on that same night it
was like Marie wakes up in bed and then
there's a jump scare with Frank next to
her like she sits up like that and then
she goes like to lay back down and then
Frank's like you know what I mean but
she didn't say she saw it was a Frank
that was Mr Hanky
[Laughter]
it could have been Mr Hanky Maybe
but yeah so she didn't say she saw that
so I guess they just did that for like
kind of like a cheap effect or whatever
so uh so at this point Marie and Chris
are like okay we're gonna have to call
another investigator because that first
one isn't going to come back
so the one that is that they called is
David considine who I feel like if you
know anything about like if you watch a
haunting if you've watched all the
paranormal shows I feel like he's kind
of famous like in paranormal circles not
as famous as the Warrens but
he's up there you know what I mean like
as far as like demonologists go and he
was on here like talking
so um so he comes over and Dave thinks
uh of course that using the Ouija board
because as soon as they said oh we used
a Ouija board he's like oh
shame uh yeah the Ouija summoned a demon
and also tells them that they never
should have burned it which [__] I'm not
even a demonologist and I could have
told him that but you know everybody
knows that all you have to do is watch
like all the paranormal shows and they
tell you that exact same thing
so yeah so he's like it's all you guys
fault pretty much he didn't say that but
that's what I was thinking so demon Dave
which is what I started calling him
that's what I started calling him in my
notes I just wrote down in team and Dave
and uh he comes to the house with
another like a another paranormal
investigator like psychic Clairvoyant
person named I think what they say her
name was Barbie Hyde or something or
November Barbie Hyde what a weird name I
mean it's not that weird but I don't
know it's just a weird name to like
those two words to go together I guess
so they come to the house and they said
as soon as they came in they felt really
really uncomfortable
they said the interesting thing was when
they first met Julie
um that she was the only member of the
family that didn't seem scared
Dave starts to suspect that Julie might
be a natural medium that she's just been
seeing ghosts her whole life and like
it's not weird to her I guess because
she doesn't know any different
so Dave is kind of going through the
house and he sees
okay so he's in this room and there's
like a like a candle sconce thingy right
and the kid was pretty snazzy like the
candles were gold and the thing was gold
and it was It was kind of shiny
and the candle was like dripping and I
was like oh did it just get really hot
in the room and like the candles are
melting but no demon Dave said that it
was ectoplasm and I was like uh okay if
you say so I mean I just thought the
candle was melting but I wasn't there so
I don't really know but yeah so he's
apparently sees ectoplasm and he's like
oh that's the first time I ever saw
ectoplasm I'm like okay they don't bring
it up again so
but I think that's the first they don't
really talk a lot about ectoplasm on
haunting do they I think that's like the
only time that he's ever brought it that
they've ever brought it up there's only
a couple Poltergeist cases that ever men
mentioned anything like ectoplasm one of
them was that case from I think from The
Entity they found something some kind of
sticky fluid in there they had it
analyzed and it was blood plasma
yeah remember that yeah I think I wrote
I think that was in the Hannity case
yeah
that's the closest thing I've ever heard
of that pretty weird
might have been made up they just found
that and called it ectoplasm ectoplasm
comes from
1800 seances and it was stuck in
cheesecloths stuck up with some chick
snatch yeah pretty much that's all it
was it's like look it's good
notice it has a sexual smell to it
because they would say that it has a it
has it had a Musky smell to it what was
upper snatch yeah that's why yeah yeah
Nature's purse that's where you hide
stuff yeah
to her face
all those old school like Victorian
spiritualists like the Seance tricks I
love that [__] I love that [__] I love
reading about that stuff like all the
tricks they were all fake but it's like
I liked the tricks because some of them
were pretty clever you know what I mean
I've never seen them as a kid printed in
books and I was you know a teenager
um I I think it was after I think it was
after the at Mammoth Mountain
and they they were creepy they are
creepy pictures and I was like could
that be real you know what I mean
looking at it as an adult now no it's
fake
but I I really could I suspected it as
being fake but I was so part of me that
said well [__] I saw some [__] that's
not supposed to exist and I Know It
exists that might exist too you know
yeah no it's fake
but I like I like the pictures though
like the pictures still look cool and
creepy even if you know they're fake
they're still cool looking I was one
time when I was in New York they had um
they had a thing I think it was at the
Met actually I can't remember if I said
the met or if it was that moment I'm
pretty sure if it was it was at the Met
and they had
um what do they call what do they call
that they had like a special thing where
they had like these big two rooms and
they had all of that Victorian Spirit
photography yeah like um and it was
really cool it's like it was really cool
to like see all the actual photos and
they had like a huge collection it was
like really really awesome
but yeah because it's because I love all
that stuff and I'm fascinated by
exoplasm because it just seems so
[__] random it seems like a random
thing to have come up with you know what
I mean well they have to come up with
some kind of gag for them right that's
it's like what yeah what what'll look
really impressive that I can like stick
up my nose or yeah stick in my veg or
whatever I think they started off they
wanted to be able to blow smoke yeah but
you couldn't hide a cigarette and you'd
smell it and they would know what that
was so the closest thing well I'll just
hide a cloth and I'll say it comes out
like smoke and we'll take a picture of
it real quick yeah and then we'll say
yeah it was a smoke like emanation that
came out of the mouth and the nose
yeah we don't know where it came from it
smells funny though
because that's what the Witnesses were
saying yeah
like it never occurred to them but it's
like they were believers
Victorian era
you know what I mean they're not gonna
they're not gonna [__] think that
that'd be rude to come up with some [__]
like that but I also heard of some
Victorian
stuff that were rumored at the time that
one one of those mediums that was the
most popular one it was rumored that
well the reason why it was so popular is
because she was giving everybody crotch
shots and in the dark [__] giving
dudes hand jobs
and stuff like that and they were doing
sexual stuff in the Seance so they'd
have her back right
yeah yeah I could see that yeah and
because you could justify it because
you'd be like oh she's in a trance or
yeah it's some good spirits doing it
right yeah he got plausible tonight no
yeah even though she had like a
history of [__] prostitution in her
background you know what I mean [__]
but yeah it's not that no of course not
this is hey I mean she like parlayed her
talents yeah some other [__] you know
they're made good for her
she probably like made a lot of money
doing that yeah she's like [__] you
know yeah jerking some dude in front of
it in front of her wife and [__] in
front of his wife in the [__]
Victorian era yeah she probably thought
getting a big tip too yeah she probably
thought that was [__] hilarious she's
like man dumb ass [__] [__] dumb
[__]
[__] civilians
right I mean seriously
yeah so uh so yeah there's some
actoplasm dripping from the candles
there even though like I said I suspect
it was just melted wax but whatever
um so yeah so he's basically like okay
yeah you got a demon for sure
um and it's trying to make everybody
like angry and fearful and stuff like
that because that's what demons feed on
that's their favorite food and uh yeah
he wants to possess the family
so the paranormal team
is now for people like they keep coming
back like a bunch of times like the
first time it's just him and Barbie and
then he comes back with like two extra
people so they come back with all the
equipment like you know the cameras and
all the [__] EMF readers and all that
kind of crap
um in case they need proof for the
Catholic church in case they want to do
an exorcism right so they have to have
like all this documentation
so Chris he takes uh Paul and Angela the
other two kids like he takes them to a
hotel to get them away from it but Julie
they actually ask uh the mom and Julie
to stay in the house because they figure
that Julie since she seems to be the
focus of the activity then she'll
probably like increase the likelihood of
something happening like her being there
now while they're setting up the
equipment
The Tech Guy
hears noises from upstairs did he say it
sounded like bowling balls I thought
that's what he said it's not like
bowling balls he said it's not like
bowling balls rolling he said there was
nobody upstairs like everybody was
downstairs
um but he heard something that sounded
like bowling balls rolling around and he
said he also felt like somebody was
watching him yeah
um they also had a thing where like that
same face that came out of the kids wall
like came out the ceiling but the guy
didn't say he saw that so I'm just gonna
say they did that for a fact he didn't
say holy [__] like a face came out of
the ceiling he didn't say anything like
that but like as you always gotta watch
it because
I don't know if they actually saw that
or not
um and then
this we cracked up at this point because
um so yeah so he apparently like hears
this stuff and maybe he saw the face
coming out of the ceiling or whatever
and then he goes on the radio and calls
Dave considine and he's basically like I
need some holy water and I'm just like
how [__] awesome is that but like he
was
he's like I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
the the CB radios and I'm gonna get in
the other room they're ham they're the
ham radius whatever and they're gonna
and I'm gonna be in the other room and
he's gonna go I need some holy water
you're doing that [__] they're doing
that [__] [__] uh in the episode the
little he was like yeah it was like
really serious about it I need some holy
water
a little FRS
I want to like call somebody and say I
need some pretty much holy water real
quick
my ass off just because that [__] I
don't know that situation just really
like I just found that really really
funny for you radio operators out there
imagine you're on gmrs and just out of
the blue gmrs Channel [__] four and
[__] out of the blue somebody goes I
need some holy water in here quick right
now it's an emergency no guys I'm on my
way I'm on my way just hold on just hold
on
you're [__] funny man
what the [__] is that
I would you would have to find out what
that was because that's like holy crap
that would be like now I just want to do
it just for a joke just because just
because it made me laugh so hard when he
did it on the show because it was it was
just like super serious and it was like
really important [__] it's like you
really needed some holy water
so yeah so uh shortly after that after
we were done laughing
um one of the psychics it wasn't Barbie
it was like one of the other ones
um I don't think it was Barbie oh no
maybe it was Barbie okay so Barbie
she gets pushed down the basement stairs
apparently by an unseen Force
uh yeah so she wasn't hurt badly but
yeah she got uh pushed down the stairs
and then
when I was reading rereading through my
notes like right before we started the
live stream I like cracked up again
because I had just ran I had forgotten
that I'd done this but I just randomly
wrote in my notes Dave has penis hair
yeah
I was like and I remember because like
not actual David considine but the actor
that's playing him in the episode he has
like this really long thin face yeah and
a high forehead and then he has this
hair this parted in the middle and kind
of poofy a little bit it's part in the
middle it sure sound like a circumcised
head of a damn dick yeah so I was like
look he's a [__] he's a [__]
I was like yeah that's not the most
super flattering hairstyle for that and
I was like oh my God he does look it
does look just like parted in the middle
and then sweat back so you got that down
look like that little [__] robot from
Buck Rogers
what the [__] was that Phoebe no that
was that was it had a little deadly
friend a little [__] another robot he
carry around on his chest
yeah that's right a little kid in a
[__] suit yeah
yeah yeah well he had a kid like that
what's that Tweaky Tweaky or something
Twinkie Twinkie
yeah Twinkie there no I think it's
Tweaky Tweaky wasn't it I don't know I
thought it was tweaky
I don't know yeah I don't know it
doesn't matter because I think the first
time I saw that show I was like Twinkie
but yeah so I just left because I put
Dave has penis hair just randomly in the
[__] notes it's like a Dorothy Hamill
haircut except his was a [__] it was
like short it was like short and it's
like really long yeah you know what I
mean and so I was like yeah it does kind
of look like you like a bulbous like
kind of a penis up there I was just like
hopefully he just his hairdresser was
like from 82 man 83. that's a retro this
is supposed to be 1998. I don't know
when this [__] was filmed but it was the
actual story took place in 1998.
so uh so yeah penis hair so so anyway uh
Dave uh suggests where we're gonna
gather all the evidence we can gather uh
and we're gonna get the church to do an
exorcism which you know that's even
because I feel like most of these
episodes when they want to do that
there's the church is always like nah
we're not gonna do that but like this
one it seemed kind of easy so what's up
with an exorcism dude we're not gonna do
that
look all that yeah that's well yeah well
they well they always act maybe I kind
of feel like the Warrens are usually
kind of like
um yeah we'll try to get an extras in
them but like they never nobody ever
wants to do it you know what I mean they
had their own Exorcist remember yeah he
was a non-denominational Exorcist yeah
he's a freelance freelance Exorcist like
Beetlejuice he's a freelance bio
Exorcist So uh so yeah
so on the next uh visit they because
like I said they've been coming back and
forth uh you know and so they bring a
clairvoyant um on there to see if there
are human ghosts too or just the
Diabolical
that's what he kept calling them yeah it
whatever like he just kept calling it
The diabolical
I don't know if that's uh if that's just
because that's what they call it or I
don't know
so The Clairvoyant who I just called
declare like in like Claire big letters
uh gets drawn to the particular room
where Julie sleeps and it seemed like
Julie was sleeping and then she was just
in there staring at her I'm like that's
pretty weird like don't do that
but uh The Clairvoyant says the The
Entity hides in Julie and uses her and I
was like okay
uh so yeah and then at this point like I
guess The Clairvoyant and the mom are in
Julie's room and she's sleeping or she's
laying there like and her eyes are open
and she looks all freaked out and
everything and then the door I'm
assuming it's the closet door like kind
of creaks open
and then Julie starts looking like
really really scared and then she does
that whole thing like you see in a lot
of exorcism movies where she like sits
up really quick and then like her eyes
go all black you know what I mean yeah
you want some ice uh sure yeah yeah
running out of ice because it's hot in
here the ice is melting
and then
um so yeah so Julie does that like whole
like thing like in The Exorcist and
then The Clairvoyant gets thrown back
and it's almost kind of like I thought
they implied that like she got possessed
for a second because I thought that Dave
considine said that she looked like an
animal or she looked like she had like a
predator kind of face so I guess maybe
the the demon was like what's on like
like went into her for a second I'm not
really sure
so um
so basically she says no there's just
there's no other ghost in the house
there's just one demon and this one
demon is pretending to be frank and that
little blonde boy remember that they saw
early on like in this whole Shenanigans
um because you know like Dave is very
seriously explaining it's like well you
know demons they like to pretend that
they're more than one they like to make
themselves seem bigger than they are you
know what I mean yeah like puffing
themselves up like like a kitty putting
their fur out you know what I mean
um so yeah he's like yeah they are
legion so that's what they're doing so
they're like pretending to be others
just to [__] with people
so the team uh eventually apparently
like uh collects enough evidence to
convince the Church of doing an exorcist
so it's you know easy
and uh so they get an exorcist in there
Now The Exorcist apparently says that he
doesn't think that Julie
can technically be possessed
because her disability makes her
incapable of choosing good or bad
like because I guess like to be
possessed you almost have to like this
seems a little bit like victim blaming
but I kind of feel like they are like
well
people that get possessed they must have
done something to like bring it on like
played with a Ouija board or something
like that but I guess because he's
saying that because Julie was disabled
that she didn't have the capacity to
choose so therefore she could not be
possessed but she can be oppressed which
I'm not really sure what the difference
is
but you know it's not really my area of
expertise frankly
so um then there is so that while
they're in the kitchen talking about
this like apparently there's like a
the demon makes this there's like a
knife on the kitchen counter and it kind
of like rattles like it's gonna go like
it's gonna stab the priest or whatever
and I'm like that's all the demon can do
come on but you know what I mean you'd
think he would go
but he didn't it just kind of rattled
and then the priest is like oh we better
get started then Demon's gonna stab me
or whatever
so uh so then they then they do the they
just do the minor extras I'm just a
little just a little exorcism they're
not doing a major one they're just doing
a minor exorcism
and while they're doing it I guess they
have Julie sitting on the couch in the
middle and then they have like one
Clairvoyant on one side one Clairvoyant
and this is like you know
flanking her like on either side or
whatever
and then they said that Julie who
normally like didn't get angry or
anything like that because she was you
know just happy all the time but it's
like she seemed to get like really
really angry and then like all the
lights started flickering in the room
like all the different lights sort of
flashing on and off and then they said
that Julie started like raking at the
air like like she was trying to [__]
like claw somebody or some [__] like
that fighting the demons fighting the
demons Conan yeah and the demons were
coming for Conan we just tied down the
ground you know what I mean Valerius
[__] fighting the demons that's what
they're talking about
um yeah so then her eyes go black again
because you know it's it's an exorcism
movie your eyes have to go black at some
point
and then she just kind of like stares at
the priest like all scary and everything
and then uh there are three loud bangs
and that was apparently the demon
leaving
yeah
um [__] out of here yeah yeah yeah
yeah Slam in the door yeah and then he
gunned the motor of his yeah of his
demon car [__] all this
and it was like a backfire yeah that's
what I was thinking I was like what is
[__] you guys I'm going home bam yeah
it's just gonna like leave in the
[__] house I was like uh all right he
just like took his ball and went out
uh so yeah so they're like after that so
that was pretty much it like the lights
flickered the three loud bangs and then
they were like oh the house felt lighter
it smelled better I was like yeah
there's that smell of snack that you
think they didn't say that they didn't
say roses but that's what I was yeah
that she recorded the smell of Santa no
I didn't we got to find that I know I
gotta find that I remember what episode
that was in I got we gotta yeah somebody
somebody in there some one of them one
of our regulars probably knows what
episode that's from the smell of
sanctity
yes
you're [__] Lorraine Warren praying
the rose water yeah yeah I was expecting
[__] smells sanctity was [__]
Lorraine went down to the damn 7-Eleven
stopped she stopped off at the [__]
mobile fill up her [__] car and saw
those damn little air fresheners [__]
from the inside of your car they became
like a little banaka can remember yeah
yeah I remember if I can do to buy this
if I could hide the weed smell in the
car
that's all I was
get the rose one and she's looking doing
in this exorcism and nobody's looking
foreign
bought the [__] at first if I could
cover up Ed's farts
he's probably in the car far and she
she's like Jesus Christ dead
Ed came up with that probably he's like
look bring that to the exorcism with us
I mean that's the ghost smell chasing
away evil spirits it's like why does the
ghost smell like Febreze
that is the smell of scent
yeah I was like no I'm pretty sure
that's Febreze
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny I just had like a
really funny
um mental picture of Ed and Lorraine
like in their car yeah and then Ed over
there in the passenger seat part no he
drive yeah he wouldn't let the Rain
Drive he's too much of it right yeah he
was just like yeah like [__] just
look at you or whatever I just look at
it and know that dude's farter
[Laughter]
he'd have his 16 year old girlfriend in
the backseat farting she'd be spraying
his ass
[Laughter]
laughs
a little girl doing [__] Lorraine's
wet we're rolling down yeah
[Laughter]
I was thinking
yeah she looks back at them glad I got
you around because I don't I'm sick of
him
you gotta do it
yeah
so uh so yeah
anyway
so yeah so the demon leaves with three
bangs because that's just what happens
uh house smelled better bloody blah and
they said that the house stayed at peace
for the next few days but then Marie
apparently goes out in the backyard and
sees that swing moving by itself again
outside in the backyard
and then the narrator Anthony call he
says the demon is gone but the exorcism
didn't destroy the evil and I'm like
how do you figure
like what the demon was causing the evil
right
but apparently they didn't really go
into that they just kind of said oh well
the demon left with with a bang
but now there's like there's still evil
lurking around like so what's doing it
now I don't know but yeah so the Evil's
still around I I don't know if he just
meant evil was still around like in a
more General sense or I don't really
know
um so not too long after that they
decide [__] this place and then they
move
and I guess they're like apparently
still haunted by evil or by the
Diabolical or whatever but I have to say
like the end of the show was a little uh
uh anti-climactic because I was just
kind of like wait that was it yeah and
then like the credits rolled and I'm
just like what happened this was an okay
episode uh it wasn't one of my favorites
uh I I tend not to like any of the
exorcism episodes I think the X the
it's an exorcism so you know how the
story is going to go yeah and a lot of
times the the phenomena that's reported
during these exorcism isn't all that
impressive I like more of the ones that
fall under the
uh you know under Poltergeist or ghost
you know like hungry ghosts that one was
a lot better episode uh
especially when you had witnesses that
wanted to talk about it you know show
their faces and talking about it or you
know what about Mr Gordy then we you
know one of the pilot episodes that was
a good one yeah you know just I don't
really like the exorcism
uh episodes a lot of them are exorcism
episodes I feel like yeah they're kind
of samey they are Yeah well yeah because
you know it's gonna go as soon as they
call and then they always do this thing
at the end where he's like like at the
end and everybody like freaks out their
eyes turn black like [__] rattles and
all those and then they're like oh the
smell of sanctity that's all they were
uh yeah Oracle said
oh no I just imagined Ed Lorraine doing
a commercial for air freshener yeah and
the smell of sanctity is the tagline
yeah
mango says uh what
Lorraine had her own feminine hygiene
products called the spell mistake to D2
We had a whole line of them yeah she's
like mass and Gill douches yeah just all
that kind of [__] [__] yeah
I don't know I almost thought of this
but it's like you know how they had they
used to have I don't know if they didn't
make it anymore but they used to have
fds that's feminine deodorant sprayer
yeah
I just remember a long time ago seeing
uh George Carlin like one of his
stand-up things and he's like what about
a feminine deodorant spray called Sprint
he's like you never forget the name and
I'm like he's right I never did I saw
that years and years ago I'm like oh my
God how [__] awesome would that be
and the thing about it is like you
couldn't have got away with it back then
but now you probably could oh yeah hell
yeah you could you could probably get
away with calling something Sprint
nowadays it's not a bad word it's just
like suggestive
predicting the future a lot of it came
true where over to over time Fuddruckers
became butt [__] all right just [__]
like this well like I said right away
with more and more is driving on you
know
[__] Starbucks was a [__] brothel
a full latte was a [__]
yeah sure yeah just to give it enough
time that's how degenerate it'll get
I'm just saying that's like I I think
that would be funny they would sell a
million like even if you didn't need it
it's like I'm just gonna buy it just
because of that you know what I mean
mango said I just finished watching uh
Skinnamarink on shutter curious movie
has some creepy Vibes about it with a
running time an hour and 40 minutes it's
just too long would have been a better
short yeah I could see that um I will
say that if you liked the vibe of it but
you want something shorter
the same guy um Kyle Edward ball I think
his name is he made a I think I
mentioned in this on my review but he
made a um like a shorter I don't know
how to say it's a version of it it's not
exactly the same but it's very very
similar and it's called heck and it's on
YouTube and it's pretty much the same as
skinamarink like the same kind of vibe
but it's only like half an hour long and
uh I've watched that too and that's
actually like really really cool but
yeah if you liked skinamarink but
thought it was too long it's like you
probably really like heck because that's
only like 30 35 minutes but it's like
very very similar
so we're talking about um oh we're
talking about the holy water before like
Ben said sounds like the lost boys when
the Frog Brothers run into a church and
fill their water pistols at the holy
water font yeah that's right I forgot
about that that's a that's a good movie
yeah I'm just I still want to do that
[__] holy water gag like over the
radio like you just need it right away
for something
um yeah the demon was attracted to evil
maybe I'm just kind of like I don't know
I didn't get it I did I don't I know
that a lot of these just don't have like
a big
finale or whatever but it's like this
one it seemed like they
didn't really explain like what happened
at the end maybe they didn't know
because they were yeah just handed maybe
not yeah but yeah I did kind of feel
like the end was a little bit
anti-climactic on that one well it's
supposed to be a real story and not
fiction so it's not it doesn't have to
be confined it doesn't have to have a
plot yeah but usually they'll say
something like oh they moved away but
the ghosts were still haunting which is
which is fine
um but this one I was kind of confused
because they're like oh well the Demon's
apparently gone but not
I don't know maybe Julie just has like
all kind of demons floating around
uh Oracle says uh Jenny I just started
reading a book called Dracula's Child by
J.S Barnes It's a sequel to uh stoker
told through journal entries and
correspondence you might like it oh that
does sound good actually yeah I'll have
to like uh check that out at some point
like I said I'm not getting as much time
to read as I used to which really sucks
but
because man I used to put up a book
review every week but I don't have time
to do that [__] anymore that's for sure
but and I have like a whole bunch of
books like checked out in my Kindle that
I haven't been able to read but I will
get around to them eventually
so do you have anything you would like
to add to this particular case no
[Laughter]
no no no it was it was uh just kind of a
middling episode for uh
for like uh the better seasons of of the
haunting yeah I mean this has been a
real good one for like season 11. yeah
you know but for uh you know there it
was just okay
well I'm kind of trying to tell you what
the how credible this case is there's
not enough information here you know but
doesn't matter they just tell a story
yeah I mean I don't know what happened
maybe it didn't yeah yeah I'm not
particularly concerned over whether it
really has I suspect that most of these
probably didn't happen or it didn't
happen the way that they are portrayed
on the show some of these but you know
they're just fun to watch I just find I
I kind of like approach them the same
way I would approach a movie you know
what I mean having seen paranormal stuff
it does happen I'm not a disbeliever
just I'm a disbeliever in a lot of the
mainstream stories a lot of times
they're blown out of proportion a lot of
the good [__] isn't really well known
because people don't want to talk about
it and a lot of the good [__] is stuff
that wouldn't end up on an episode
anyway because it's stuff like
near-death experiences and spontaneous
out of body experiences things like
dreaming true or you know just something
you guess something right Beyond All
Odds and it turned out that yeah your
feelings are right about it you know
that kind of [__] that's that's more
common in the Paranormal world
do I think there's ghosts
I know there's bad houses went into
house and it's just [__] bad
everybody that went into it just but
nothing ever happened there just
feelings dreams
oh lived in it for about a year
but nothing ever really physically
happened
so and I think some of these haunting
cases are actually cases like the bad
house case like like I've talked about
so you can't have a whole episode of
people saying yeah I had weird feelings
here you had a dream here and yeah that
might get a lot I mean so you have to
fill that out with something happening
something physical happened and maybe
they might lie about that part of it
to get to get to get that story Into the
[__] series and get it on TV it's got
to have more than that yeah because it's
got to be like cinematic to an extent
you can't just have a bunch of people
going yeah like ooh I felt really cold
or I felt like somebody was watching me
because that doesn't translate well to
visual media everybody went in a house
got scared they didn't want to [__]
walk down the hallways by themselves
they had to stand outside the damn
doorway while the girls were taking a
piss in the bathroom and [__] like that
which that's the way that house me and
Eric lived in you had to guard if you if
you brought a girl over the house
she didn't walk down and wanted to go to
the bathroom she'd want you to walk down
the hallway with her and wait outside
the door
and I said this is a creepy house and
because yeah this house is [__]
creepy but you look at it was just a
nice Victorian house but it was 100
something years old
and it just had an eerie feeling a bad
feeling about the house
see I'd be curious to like go in there I
don't like I said I don't think I've
ever experienced anything like that not
in a house anyway
and I've even been weird I've even lived
in a house my grandfather's old house
which isn't there anymore got torn down
but I lived there for years and that
house was supposedly according to my mom
and all of her siblings that house was
supposedly super haunted because they
had all kind of [__] happen like they
had um they said we used to hear people
walking around the roof we used to have
our blankets torn off and everything
like that like when they were kids
but I lived there a long time and I
never felt anything bad there or
anything weird I was I I wasn't scared
of that house I thought it was cool
yeah me and Eric we were fresh out of
the army we were in Korea together and
we were in the 101st Airborne together
for four [__] years we we were
[__] left
two days apart he waited two days I ETS
and he waited two days for me to get to
get out because we were going to Boston
together we drove up there together in
his car
so we had seen [__] you know and we got
a [__] great deal on that through a
realtor and [__] went in there and
[__] that house is sucking bad bad it
had a bad feeling about that house
and it
it changed hands a couple times while we
were in there we never paid rent that
was some weird [__] and then a new new
guy showed up who owned the house and he
says you guys can stay here
but you know eventually you guys have to
leave because I'm gonna remodel this
house and then like a couple months
later he says all right man you guys got
to go I'll give you [__] 60 days
notice I said all right and then we left
but um
it was a bad house
and but nothing physically ever happened
so I can't prove it yeah I can't I can't
really prove it to myself in on that one
because I'd already seen that
Poltergeist when I was a kid that [__]
[__] was moving and all the witnesses
you know man and Uncle my cousin and
everything
so I know that that was some paranormal
[__] this one
everybody else felt it too but we never
really could prove it because
nothing physically ever moved
you know I felt like I came under attack
one time but I couldn't see anything
yeah just waves of [__] emotion you
know yeah I threatened to burn the house
down and it went away
no don't do that yeah thread it yeah I
said [__] you know I can't leave so I
got nowhere to go you keep [__] me
this this is
I don't burn this [__] house down I
got nothing to lose here and it and it
didn't ever do that again but I could
feel it was in the house Tom keeping
them ghosts in line I kept that [__] in
line
because I wasn't lying
because I I [__] said I'm gonna go
out to the [__] car and [__]
siphon out two gallons of gasoline and
I'm gonna burn this [__] house down
you keep [__] with me
give it away
that's good that's what you gotta do
because that was the only leverage I had
never see him do that on a hunting no so
this isn't my house this is your house
you know I haven't paid rent four months
and nothing Saturday
all right right you don't even have it's
not even haunted house it's just a
[__] haunted field yeah lame
[Laughter]
all right so I guess we will wrap it up
because I'm getting pretty tired and I
need to probably
chill out and relax a little bit
before I gotta go to bed and then get up
again and do the [__] over again
uh so yeah we will be back on Wednesday
night for the main show and I think this
is going to be a cool show because I
would probably have never come with this
idea on my own but one of our listeners
uh Celtic Angel 73
uh gave me this idea and even gave me a
bunch of ideas for like different cases
and stuff it's basically going to be a
show about people who survived like
really [__] up [__] like you know what
I mean so um we're gonna be talking
about uh Terry Joe
um dupero duper alt whatever it's like
she's called the sea orphan that's like
a really [__] up story
um you know the woman that fell like out
the plane and like was in the jungle for
11 days and stuff like that so it's like
amazing survival stories sounds good so
yeah so I've got like a bunch of those
so we'll talk about uh some of those so
it should be yeah because I was watching
some documentaries on my lunch hour
today and like reading through on my
notes and everything I was like some of
these some of these stories are [__]
unbelievable like that people survive
through this [__] but yeah so that's
what we'll be doing on Wednesday night
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that so thank you very much for hanging
out with us this evening and remember to
like and share and comment and all that
other kind of stuff for the algorithm
and we will see you guys again on
Wednesday night good night